chess.com is here with thomas brody
sangster who played u.s champion benny
watts in the queen's gambit
now netflix most watched scripted
miniseries of all time
thank you thomas for taking the time to
talk with me and all the chess.com users
thank you um i've read that you learned
how to play drums for love actually and
you learned how to play guitar with your
left hand
to play paul mccartney uh this role
though you had already played a previous
character
that was in the chess community this was
kind of like your second time
playing a chess correct character did
that make it a little bit easier to step
into our subculture
um i mean somewhat yeah i mean the the
other thing
i did was i mean i was playing um a
quite
talented chess player but it was more
about um world war two resistance and
um uh it was it was quite a kind of a
side part of it
um and it was a kind of hunt between me
and uh and a big
nazi badly that was kind of coming after
me so there was a kind of crossover
between that and chessboard and
this was much more chess focused i see
what uh these three disciplines though
what is more difficult to make
look convincing on camera drums guitar
with your left hand or chess
um
that's a hard one i mean you you just
want to do the best that you can do to
your ability because also you know
you're
that's why i love talking to you because
you know that when you when you're
pretending to be someone that is
supposedly very good at something
the main person you're thinking of is
people who are actually very good at it
and you know that they're the they're
going to be the ones that pick you apart
the most
so whether you're a drummer or a
left-handed guitarist
or um you know big big big chess player
um
you're going to be very very critical so
that's your main kind of audience that
you're going for
drums you literally have to hit them so
if you aren't in time it doesn't look
right
so you have to be perfect um
with chess it was more about the finesse
and being able to kind of just look
confident moving
chess pieces around the board um in
terms of actually
learning um openings or uh
you know really understanding the games
in which you're playing and
and the reason for taking each pieces
was kind of not quite as important
um and i suppose fingers on a on a
fretboard
are important but less obvious than
drumming so i say drumming
i'd say drumming probably we're exactly
right it's very hard to please any
subculture when a movie's made about it
but i don't know if you know this
uh this series has been heaped with
praise from inside the chess community
for accuracy and the feel of being at a
tournament so you deserve a lot of
credit for that
um there's been a lot of movies that
have made about chess during your
lifetime some of them have even been big
hollywood releases
but nothing has done what the queen's
gamut has done
to grow chess i mean it's hard to even
buy a chess set they're all sold out
our website traffic is getting five
times the normal number of users
so my question is why the queen's gambit
why do you think this was different than
all the other chess movies and series
to be honest i don't really know um i
don't um
all i do now is that um the people who
made this show
um were all phenomenally talented and
all
very willing and wanting of
creativity of wanting to tell a story
and
wanted to do it right and do it justice
and although it's very very chess
focused um that was a very very
important thing to get right
it was also just as important to make
sure that
it came across as a real story as it you
you are watching human beings and you
are
and then there's then there's also
getting it period correct and that you
know so everyone that came together to
make this project
did their utmost to make it as realistic
and as well even though it's actually
heightened you know it's a very stylized
piece as well i mean so it's not
super realistic but it's it taps into
a sense of reality that i think is
key to making something successful
people only enjoy watching stuff if they
can relate to it or if they can
kind of somewhat understand it so
making a movie or or a show requires a
huge collaboration
of a lot of people and and and
bringing those people together so that
they all work
in unity is very very key
and uh that's what we experienced on set
and the fact that
it translated to film is kind of no
surprise the surprise is that it did
very very well and people seemed to love
it i knew that it was going to be a good
a good piece but i thought it would be
in a very kind of cliquey um you know
small world of an audience um
i didn't realize it would have the reach
that it does but i think the reason that
it does that is because it's just
done it's just done well
makes sense um and in a previous
interview i've heard you praise the
hyper realism
that was assisted by some of the chess
consultants i've interviewed bruce
pandolfini about it
can you point to one or two things that
that he specifically taught you
that helped you ma uh you know become
benny watts as a chess player
well we we played several times just
back and forth and um
he he i would just take pieces and they
would go no no no
that was that was rubbish that was
rubbish do it again and i'd do it again
and you go
that was it that was it i was like i i
didn't really see the difference he was
like do it again and then
i did it again he said no no that was
rubbish dude do it again do it again
and we'll just take pieces over and out
and you just he said you know get used
to the weight of the pieces in your
hands because you're playing someone
that has moved these pieces around for
years and years and years and studied
and studied and studied
and and it kind of probably has a
relationship with each piece you know
you know
your relationship with your rooks or you
you have a favoritism of your bishops or
you
you know which pieces do you like the
most and so he kind of brought
although i wasn't really learning really
how to play chess
i was learning the what a chess player
may fall in love
with about the game and he was that was
i think that was quite clever because
there was nowhere near enough time to
actually really truly understand the
purpose of
every move and and what it all meant and
you know that takes years and years and
years of understanding
and playing so what he did was like kind
of try to teach us
how to fall in love with the game
and how to look like you know exactly
what you're doing
um and so with that there's um another
element of technique but then there's
also an element of flair
and they were quite good all of the
chess team were quite good at working
with us to try and
create individual flares of how we might
take pieces how
how we might hit the clock um
you're like beth knocks over other
people's kings which is just outrageous
um but that's her little thing and um
that adds to it um that adds to her own
little techniques so every
they were very good at like trying to
figure out everyone's little own way of
playing
so i'm curious did you either buy
osmosis or intentionally become a
slightly better player did you play some
fun games off the set
anything yeah no no i did and i even
learned a couple of openings which are
completely gone now
um but at the moment yeah we were
we were playing with some um some great
players and
we were very much invested in that world
and uh
i was excited by it i i loved it i saw
it as
you know it's a beautiful game that's
been played for hundreds and hundreds of
years and
um is kind of infinitely complicated and
the the knowledge that you have to
understand the memory of each
game that's being played in the past and
then kind of
put that into reflection of what you
need to do in front of your board and
it's just moving bits of wood around the
board that's all it is
but it's i i learned the beauty of it
and that's what i would say
that's great to hear um and there's a
scene where you uh
what we call a blindfolded game in a car
with beth doesn't literally mean
blindfolded just means without the use
of a chess set
but uh this is a skill that comes to all
chess players without ever
intentionally trying to do it it's a bit
like taking the tube every day and you
just at some point you just know the
system of london
it just happens um so i'm curious were
you around the chest enough throughout
the months of filming
where you can kind of close your eyes
and see a chess board and if i say pawn
to king four
you can visualize what that looks like
did you have enough chess in you to be
able to do that
no okay no in fact those lines are some
of the hardest lines to learn
because it was just it to me it was like
code
um and if you got one wrong it that the
whole thing didn't make sense so it had
to be spot on
perfect um so it was a very hard thing
to learn
i just learnt them as lines i was not
visualizing them as
a uh on a chess board um at all no i was
completely incapable of doing that
that's all right it takes years for most
of us so um in this series
fashion is kind of like its own
character and you were i don't know
maybe like an indiana jones but i want
to ask about the knife whose idea was it
to add the knife to your wardrobe
it was scots and you know it never comes
out stays sheathed
the whole time i don't um
it's a weird one it's a strange one but
i think it's just his own like um
just his weird little defensive thing
it's a it's another
prop that he uses to kind of unsettle
people and and to make people ask
questions um i mean that that character
he doesn't fit the archetype chess
player and i think he does that
intentionally to kind of it's probably a
tactic
i think it's a tactic to unsettle his
opponent
the fact he's just bizarre looking
strange looking and
he carries a knife i mean why would you
need a knife
um and the fact he never uses it he
never peels an orange and never does
anything with it it's
uh it might not even be real i don't
really know
i'm gonna ask you a bit of an outlandish
theory that i had when i my first
viewing of the series um
right before you played the big game
against beth in ohio at the u.s
championship
you got your two characters play a
series of blitz chess or speed chess
matches
and you win all of them almost like
you're hustling her you're taking her
five dollars every time
i'm just wondering though in like
washington square in new york city
uh sometimes hustlers they do the
typical hustle they lose a bunch of
games until they raise the stakes
i'm just wondering i don't know if
beth's character was sophisticated
enough but could she have lost those
games to you on purpose
to be able to beat you the next day in
the event where it really mattered
well i don't know uh i don't think so i
don't think so
um it's a good point uh i don't think
she'd ever heard of speed chess
or blitz chess uh and i think i
basically hustled her knowing that she i
think it was also mainly
to kind of slightly unsettle over the
next day when we're actually playing
the real game um so by that point i had
already
beaten her 10 times or something so
um i think it was more to kind of see
how she played and to slightly unsettle
her
um i don't think she lost on purpose
i've been there before i don't think she
likes losing um i mean i mean actually
most chess
players i've met during this whole thing
uh despise losing
uh it really gets to them which i found
quite anyone that competes in anything
i think just hates losing it's very
visceral um
one more idea this was not my idea uh
and this has nothing to do with your
character but
is there any chance that cleo is a kgb
agent
because that's actually if you read
anything about
cold war era chess kgb agents were
absolutely at tournaments so i'm just
curious if that could be i don't know as
well that's another
good good spot i have no idea that's a
good oh
oh i like that i'm going to say yes
because i like that as it's as a store
as a sub storyline
i'm going to ask you a question about
your subculture that i know very little
about but um
in the chess world when two chess
players meet for the first time we
always know each other's rating or maybe
even their title in chess and so it's a
very hierarchical game
you can almost never be equals as
somebody because i know you're raiding
in you know mine
is it like that in the acting world i'm
guessing you don't bump into people and
you know exactly how many baftas they've
won or something but
um is there any sort of hierarchy like
that in your world
no well there probably is um it's
i mean there's ego there's lots of ego
um
i don't really care about that too much
i i i also don't get that star struck
over people
i i only judge people on whether they're
a nice person and
then and then whether they're talented
and whether i can
you know work with them and bounce off
of them and
have fun and play in a scene um to me
there is no um
there isn't really a hierarchy i mean
you get you know when you when you join
a job
you know there's the star and then on
the call sheet you've got number one two
three four
five so you're number eight and they're
number one
but i mean that's it and it's it's it's
a bit of a joke really um it depends on
how much of a an arse they are but uh
most people actually aren't they're most
people are very nice people
um actors are perhaps a little insecure
but uh i tend to not be they
tend to be quite nice people i think and
they just want to
um play an experience and get that
they're quite excited to get to work
with someone new i mean
that's how i feel and that's my most
most of my experience with others is
that
um if you've watched other actors or if
you know
other actors um you're more excited to
work with them because you get to see
how you react with them
in a scene uh it's more of an exciting
thing than a
a one-upmanship there is no way of kind
of
winning at acting that's good to hear in
another interview you said that as a boy
you played drafts or we call it checkers
that game is very complex
is it complex enough where a series like
this could be made
out of drafts or is chess just got that
next level of complexity that makes this
series what it was
i think it's also got more character to
it though as well i mean that
there are literally different characters
on a chessboard um
i just think it's a little bit more of
an interesting game
uh it's visually just the pieces are
more interesting as well
um it's a bit more famous uh i don't
know i mean
quite possibly you can make a movie
about anything um as long as it's well
written
and well acted well shot uh it doesn't
really
matter too much what it's about so yeah
i would say so
fantastic i'm just going to ask you one
more question it's something i've wanted
to know hopefully the chess.com users do
too
if we had a chess tournament with all of
the actors not counting any of the
professional chess consultants like
bruce
who would win that chess tournament
now i never played him but apparently
jacob um i can't remember his second
name now
um jacob who plays um
photographer guy uh i can't remember his
character name either bloody yell
um apparently he's quite good um
yeah i never played him but apparently
he's actually bloody good so i would say
him
fantastic maybe we'll have to organize
that someday well thank you so much
um it's hard for me to express how much
you've done for the chess community it's
been awesome to see
um i wish you all on your career yeah
thank you thomas brodie thanks for
spending some time with us
thank you very much